simplifica -1 por la expresión entre
paréntesis menos 72 por 32 - entre
paréntesis 5 al cuadrado este es un
problema de orden de operaciones así que
recuerda al seguir el orden de las
operaciones primero debes hacer
paréntesis paréntesis
luego harás exponentes
y nota que en esta expresión si hay un
exponente en este lado después
multiplicación
división y finalmente sumar
y resta
así que abordemos el problema lo mejor
que podamos
primero evaluemos el paréntesis de aquí
por lo que tres más dos es igual a cinco
podemos continuar simplificando alguna
otra parte de la expresión que no afecte
estos corchetes por ejemplo acá tenemos
menos 5 al cuadrado en realidad estamos
restando 5 al cuadrado y debemos hacer
el exponente antes que la resta entonces
5 al cuadrado se reescribe como 25 lo
hagamos muchos pasos a la vez
primero reescribamos esta expresión como
menos 1 primos corchetes menos 7 más 2
por 5 por 5
cerramos corchetes
- 25
ahora sobre esta expresión vamos a
realizar la multiplicación primero pero
tú puedes decir hoy el primero debe
hacerse lo que hay entre paréntesis sin
embargo yo te digo que al evaluar este
paréntesis obtendrás lo mismo un -7
entonces no va a cambiar nada lo que sí
queremos es evaluar la expresión entre
corchetes antes que otra cosa de la
expresión
otra opción sería distribuir el -1 sobre
lo que hay dentro de los corchetes pero
vamos a seguir el orden de las
operaciones
así que hagamos la multiplicación antes
que la suma entonces en nuestra
multiplicación tenemos 2 por 5 y 2 por 5
es igual a 10
vamos a reescribir otra vez la expresión
no no la tienes que reescribir tantas
veces pero esta vez lo haremos para que
estemos seguros que nadie tenga dudas
entonces queda menos 1
abrimos corchetes menos 7 más
lo que acabamos de simplificar 10
cerramos corchetes
- 25
ahora podemos evaluar lo que está dentro
de los corchetes fácilmente dice menos 7
10 y para hacer fácil esto vamos a
utilizar unas pequeñas rectas
si nosotros tenemos menos 7
aquí tenemos el 0 entonces menos 7 está
del lado izquierdo de 0 y esta es una
distancia de 7 unidades
si nosotros queremos sumar 10 unidades
al menos 7 entonces a partir del menos
siete debemos movernos 10 unidades hacia
la derecha llegando hacia el 0 sabemos
que tenemos 7 unidades por lo cual nos
faltan otras 3
por lo que aquí tenemos 7-8 9-10 donde
estas tres unidades como resultado nos
dan un +3
otra forma de verlo es que estamos
sumando dos enteros de diferente signo
por lo que la suma será la diferencia de
los dos enteros o sea 10 menos 7 es
igual a 3 y el signo será el del mayor
entero en este caso es el 10 por lo
tanto la respuesta es positiva por lo
que literalmente esto quedaría como 10
menos 7 que es igual a 3 vamos a volver
a reescribir la expresión y entonces
tenemos menos 1 lo que está entre
corchetes ya lo hemos reducido a donde
más se puede y algo que hay que
mencionar aquí es que tanto los
corchetes como los paréntesis o hasta
las llaves son lo mismo en realidad los
utilizamos para diferenciar las
expresiones pero son lo mismo entonces
aquí tenemos menos 1
por 3
- 25
ahora sí siguiendo otra vez el orden de
las operaciones primero se hace la
multiplicación antes que la resta por lo
que esto me quedaría menos 1 por 3 es
igual a menos 3
- 25
- 3 - 25 es la suma de dos enteros del
mismo signo por lo que podemos sumar las
unidades 3 y 25 son 28 y como el signo
es negativo entonces los sumamos de
forma negativa por lo cual esto queda
menos 28 y terminamos